about what's planned for the month we
have Jody Gotham from keep memory alive
and Devin Constantine from Atomic Liquor
thank you both so much for being here hi
well thank you for having us well Jody
let's talk about keep memory alive you
do so much in the community and to help
everyone here in Nevada tell us a little
bit about the organization so we started
about six years ago we wanted to do a
community initiative so it was
Alzheimer's awareness month for November
so today is November 1st through the
30th we will reach out to the Community
Partners restaurants stores and each
restaurant will either have a food item
a clothing store will have a clothing
item for us and certain amount of
proceeds come back to benefit the keep
memory alive Lou Revo Center for brain
health which helps support our
educational
educational and caregiver support
programs if you go to keep
memoryallive.org you will see all the
listed restaurants that we have we have
Carson kitchen Atomic is with us today
they've been with us the entire six
years here and they're going to show you
a cocktail that we have and then also we
have Texas Holdem which is this Friday
November 4th at the event center you can
buy in at 575 dollars for an individual
ticket for 150 so come stop by and see
us this Friday November 4th for the
Texas Hold'em that's great you know
having fun but also raising money for an
important cause so Devin I'll bring you
into the conversation here as you're
making a drink I'll have you tell us
what you're making and how it feels to
be a part of this for the month of
November oh I am making our nuclear
Daiquiri uh it is like she said our
sixth year this is our first TV
interview to do this and oh welcome we
did a special tea cocktail that hits
home for us and hopefully we'll hit home
for everybody else and so how does this
work you come in and you order a drink
and you have to mention keep memory
alive how does it work for you they will
also promote it too and then you have to
let the customer know that a certain
amount of the proceeds come back to
support us
um so yeah and how does it feel to have
Partners like Atomic like are supporting
everyone in the community comes together
for that great it's great we have
bananas Pizza Downtown Summerlin
Downtown Summerlin and we have Carson
kitchen Atomic we have
um golden Tiki also and multiple others
yeah so go on to keep memorylive.org and
you'll see the list of restaurants that
we have and then also you know Jack
Binion is hosting our poker tournament
this Friday
exciting things coming up thank you so
much for making the drink Devon cheers
to everything you're doing in the
community we really appreciate you being
here Mercedes I'll send it over to you
cheers